[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con aquí entras
24 y nos acompaña jesús núñez analista
internacional y codirector del instituto
de estudios sobre conflictos y acción
humanitaria para hablar sobre la nueva
escalada de tensiones entre eeuu y rusia
recientemente la unión americana impuso
duras sanciones económicas contra rusia
y la nación respondió expulsando a 10
diplomáticos estadounidenses de su
territorio bienvenida france24 cuéntenos
qué consecuencias sobre la economía rusa
puede tener las sanciones impuestas por
eeuu tras considerar que la nación
ingirió en las elecciones presidenciales
de 2020
bueno las sanciones ya son una dinámica
regular desde al menos el año 2014
cuando rusia acabó anexionando crimea y
es cierto que han dañado en cierta
medida la economía rusa pero en
cualquier caso por decirlo de ese modo
para vladimir putin son absolutamente
llevaderas teniendo en cuenta sus
intereses geopolíticos de controlar una
zona tan especial como la península de
crimea donde tiene la base la flota de
guerra rusa por lo tanto desde ese punto
de vista cabe imaginar que moscú puede
seguir manteniendo ese mismo rumbo
puesto que son como digo sanciones
soportables queda por ver lo que puede
ocurrir a partir de esta nueva oleada en
la que ahora entramos primero con las
imposiciones por parte de joe biden y a
continuación inmediata por las
represalias que rusia está tomando
también en el mismo terreno bueno eeuu
ha advertido que tomará más acciones y
rusia no detiene su comportamiento es
esta amenaza motivo suficiente para
disuadir al kremlin
creo que claramente no la el rumbo que
ha adoptado en moscú hace tiempo ya que
está muy claramente establecido intentar
aprovechar nuevamente las situaciones
que se le plantean tanto en europa
oriental como en el asia central para
recuperar la influencia que la unión
soviética tuvo en su día al mismo tiempo
intentar inmiscuirse en los asuntos
internos de algunos de sus vecinos lo
hemos visto en el caso de bielorrusia de
forma mucho más significativa todavía en
ucrania también y como digo en algunos
países del asia central por tanto es el
rumbo es difícil que se vaya a modificar
con sanciones como los que hemos visto
hasta ahora por el otro lado los eeuu
quien está realmente reconfigurando su
agenda es decir la administración yo de
bailén no lleva ni siquiera 100 días en
funcionamiento y estamos viendo cómo con
respecto a china y también con respecto
a rusia la administración estadounidense
está intentando reconfigurar rediseñar
lo que había sido en buena medida el
desastre de la administración de donald
trump
en otro punto ahora la salud del
opositor al excel navalny eeuu ha dicho
que habrá consecuencias si éste llega a
morir en prisión como crea que actuará
rusia en el caso este líder opositor
parece claro de moscú ya lo hemos visto
en otros casos no tiene ninguna
dificultad en cuanto a sus decisiones de
eliminar a disidentes y a críticos al
régimen de vladimir putin lo ha hecho
asesinando a diferentes individuos de
diferentes disidentes y parece claro que
coronaban y está dispuesta a seguir
adelante si eso se le añade que en la
conversación telefónica que ha tenido yo
de bailén con vladimir putin hace unos
días en la que al mismo tiempo de
aplicar esas sanciones hablaba de
convocarlo a una nueva cumbre vemos que
el asunto naval bien no fue ni siquiera
mencionado podemos entender que más allá
del discurso que mantiene en términos
generales algunos países europeos y
también eeuu no parece que haya voluntad
para convertir eso en una verdadera vara
de medida del tipo de relaciones que
habían estable
por parte de sus países con moscú pero
en tanto continúa en aumento las
tensiones en la frontera con ucrania
donde rusia ha desplegado miles de
tropas que se esperan los próximos días
ante esta creciente tensión militar hay
posibilidad de un enfrentamiento directo
es evidente la acumulación de medios por
parte de rusia y eso hace pensar que una
hipótesis que cabe contemplar es la de
una posible invasión de ese país de
ucrania que para rusia es un interés
vital pero creo que es una opción muy
escasamente probable porque supondría
una operación militar para la cual de
momento rusia no tiene efectivos
disponibles estamos hablando de unos 80
mil efectivos militares entre la
península de crimea y la frontera con
ucrania
otra cosa es que moscú pretende mantener
su influencia en ucrania y tratar de
evitar como sea que ese país pase a la
órbita de la unión europea y de la otan
y es ahí donde putin está moviendo sus
peones y hasta hoy no parece que haya
habido voluntad política por parte de la
unión europea ni de la otan para poder
evitar esos movimientos y rusos luego
queda por ver todavía si esa acumulación
de medios acaba desembocando en algún
golpe puntual o se queda simplemente
como un intento de probar hasta dónde
llega la nueva administración
estadounidense pues agradecemos a jesús
núñez analista internacional y
codirector del instituto de estudios
sobre
conflicto y acción humanitaria por estar
con nosotros aquí en 24 en 5 metros con
construir en ustedes con más información
[Música]